good afternoon everyone it's so great to
be back to the farm my name is James
Paul I'm the founder and CEO of pony AI
we are a company that focused on
developing the safest most reliable and
scalable solutions for autonomous
driving
thanks for Professor for inviting me to
here and thanks for the kind
introduction today I want to take this
opportunity to really share with you
some of the experience that we had
during the last two years I want to
first start with telling you the young
potential impact of autonomous driving
aka why did we choose this field to
start as our our new company then I'll
probably spend the time to give some of
you are from strapping 101 really a
crash course so what this doesn't mean
what's the myth of this field and then
at the end of course I'm a PI being the
CEO I'll try to advertise tell you a bit
about our journey so far so I'll start
with the potential impact of advanced
driving why did we choose this field
essentially some of you I'm sure all of
you have had experience with the current
transportation system
it's neither safe efficient nor
enjoyable there's a lot of issues
problems associated with the current
system right its first road are very
congested it's not efficient most of
this our deal associated with for
example in the city traffic the
intersections actually accounts for more
than 30 percent of the delay in our
mobility but we thought our smart
traffic light controlling system without
really the system being automated and
optimized
the the congestion and the cost is
inevitable also the traffic itself is
not safe enough in fact there's a
statistics that 93 more than 93 percent
of the fatal accidents associated with
human arrows okay imagine the the the
driver can get tired there's a DUI
there's emotional factors associated
with this and also you really look at
human our sensors are all eyes and our
sensor only has the coverage of about
120 degrees so we definitely have a lot
of the blind spots we can now cover out
of all this also the current
transportation system still relies
heavily relies on the internal
combustion engine and also because of
the congestion the system are not
efficient so we actually all want to
imagine the word which a lot better than
this right in your a guessing your spare
times or in some dreaming times you
probably think about you want a
transportation system that's are less
congested that's a lot safer on the road
and also the efficiency is much higher
but just just imagine I I think the last
month actually just this Monday you'll
probably wished you had a autonomous
driving with you so that instead of
focusing on the road condition where you
go to work or go to school you can
actually in your car snatching all the
cyber monday deals right that's
potential productivity increase from the
autonomous driving is just enormous
because on average people spend more
than two hours on the road and if will
free up that time doing something more
productive the whole society will be
much better so that's why
because of the huge impact we picked
this area as the the area that we
started the Pony journey so so think
about the just rest a bit and think
about what the future can be I'm sure a
lot of you read the news that in the
last 5-10 years the whole mobility
related field is very exciting right
there's a one heart one access there's a
whole transformation of the business
model right traditionally the car o
yemm's the majority of their revenue
comes from selling vehicles and now with
the emergence of uber and lyft and DD
and alike all the OEMs are thinking of
changing the car selling business
interest service based model so the
right sharing becomes a more popular
form of transportation and then on the
other angle you look at there's a lot of
new forms of transportation coming up
I'm sure you've read read about
autonomous driving vehicles there's
autonomous flying cars there's a
Hyperloop and many many other forms so
so you can imagine in the next five to
ten years the whole mobility related
field will be very exciting and I my
personal view is all these forms of
Transportation has its need has its
place in the future mobility right the
the Hyperloop the high-speed rail
probably will be the 500 mile ish
transportation and please be the
majority takers for that and then the
wait for ups I say for example it's a
ride from here to Airport will be
something like a Hyperloop or really if
you're really in a hurry it will be the
flying cars but majority majority of the
transportation will still handle in the
local commute right you go to work you
go to a shopping and that will still be
handled by the autonomous driving
vehicles
it's because of that and you probably
all of you heard about ai ai is sort of
the buzzword of the day and this AI
believe in fact let them live step one
was that back I I had many booms and
busts before right the the in fact the
last booming was in the early 90s that's
actually when I start learning computer
science the ex the expert system was the
buzzword but what made this AI booming
different than the previous ones was
this is the one where AI technology is
actually being used in the real industry
to transform the existing system and
among all the potential industries that
can be transformed by AI technology this
is a report done by earlier this year by
making see that all the top industry
that can be or will be transformed by AI
or mobility related that just shows you
how vast is this field will be in fact
because of that promise in the
investment community it's also become
very hard this is just shows you the
chain over several years the average
size and the total amount of investment
poured into autonomous driving related
companies it's not just the total
amounts its average deal size is also
increased in fact in the last two years
more than half of the investment was
from cooperative players that means the
big columns and the tech giant's started
noticing the potential of this
technology and start in heavily invested
in this just a case in point this is a
in the summer Morgan Stanley come up
with a report that put a potential value
- way more at Wapping 175 billion plus
this she just shows you that the whole
investment community sees the potential
of the field so i since this is not the
majority of my talk I just lived through
just shows you what's the potential
impact of all this and and why we are
interested in this now I'll spend some
time to tell you what Tom's driving
really mean I want to be again I want to
be other faster in my presentation if
you have any questions please do feel
free to ask and I'll try to leave more
time at the end for for Q&A so what'd
you think about hounds driving you might
think of something like this a very
futuristic looking vehicles with
completely redesign of the current
vehicles this might be the case in ten
years maybe in five but these days
rather most of them are Tom's driving
vehicles look like this
it's a retrofitting of the existing
vehicles we by putting on different
types of sensors by putting a computer
into the vehicle and then loaded with
advanced algorithms and then we can let
the computers to drive the vehicle
instead of driving by a human
so the typical sensors that put in the
vehicle are stuff like a GPS and IMU
it's actually it all our smartphones we
have GPS and I am umu is the inertial
measurement but what's used in the
vehicle is just a lot more accurate and
a lot more advanced than what's in our
smartphones you can give the positioning
of the vehicle a lot more accurate in
addition we put on different types of
sensors there's Elijah the mechanism of
a lighter is actually quite
straightforward essentially it's a
device
it's sort of like the wrench finder that
people use to measure the size of a room
right essentially it's emitting a light
laser line and by either measure the
time of travel right you you measure the
time divided by two that's the distance
or there's a new types of lighter comes
in by measuring the frequency change and
and other things then there's some other
types of sensors there's a traditionally
there's camera because camera is cheap
and the camera can has high resolution
and also there's a radar the minami
millimeter reader that can actually
actually detects the speed of moving
objects they're definitely there's new
types of sensor coming in so you can
think of this essentially is equipped
the vehicle with eyes with ears so that
I can detect what's around it then the
next question you might ask is that why
now right you probably read about
autonomous driving the history of it is
that as early as back in the in in the
world war ii that's eighty years ago
people were people were already dreaming
about or thinking about autonomous
driving but why it took so long and what
happened in the last five years that
made this possible in fact I think it's
several things it's not just one thing I
think it's several things happen roughly
in this timeframe that makes me this
become possible the first one is the
vehicle technology is advanced in the
old form of vehicle when we actually
turn the wheel the wheel itself will
actuate the actual reader to do the
turning right when we break it's a it's
the same thing but in the modern vehicle
essentially we're not actually
controlling the actual reader directly
but rather when we turn the wheel it was
transformed into a digital signal
by measuring how much you'll turn it's
sending a different signal to the
vehicle so that in vehicle industry we
call drive-by-wire essentially it's by
the digital command so you can imagine
in the old days if you want machine to
drive a vehicle the the most ways in
fact even the first or the second topper
challenge or Tom's driving challenge
most of the Tom's training vehicle was
done by adding a new actuator into the
vehicle but in these days especially you
can imagine that we can add a device in
there by sending the same signal into
the vehicle and control the vehicle so
the drive-by-wire system is is the first
factor the second is the computer chips
and the computing power is getting a lot
better a lot better than before that's
thanks to the Moore's law so the
on-board computer these days can handle
are much more complicated algorithms and
then the the as I mentioned that they're
so new types of sensors especially the
emergence of lidar that makes the
measurement a lot more accurate then I
think I think comes what's next is the
Big Data algorithm and AI technology so
combining with the emergence of all
these technologies atoms driving
suddenly becomes possible that doesn't
mean it's easy but at least now it
becomes attainable so then what is the
definition of autonomy in the vehicle
this is the this is just one type of
levels that are defined by SAE is a
society of autonomy automotive engineers
it's actually it's it's without knowing
the details so you can think of what we
talked about the high high autonomous is
mostly in the level four level five the
main difference is
level five we're talking about all
weather conditions or traffic conditions
without any human intervention level
four is still a very high automation but
it still requires some restrictions for
example in a very heavy rain may be even
heavier than the ring we have today
then the vehicles might be out of
service but in most normal conditions it
will be fully autonomous the level two
is actually it's more like a Tesla's can
claim the automation essentially is
something like a CC the adaptive cruise
control you do a link ap you do a
automatic stop once you see a obstacle
and the level three is is sort of in
between then really I'm not trying to
demystify the whole thing and and
trivialize it but if you really think
about how the human how the computer
drives a vehicle it's actually very
analogous to how human drives a vehicle
right for us what we learn driving it's
become so spontaneous we probably don't
even think about it
and the dissect about what have happened
in those driving but maybe you think
about it it's really when we're driving
we are constantly asking ourselves
several questions simultaneously the
first one is where am i right which lay
and my e where am I going which the
location am i right that the absolute
and the relative location of ourselves
is very important and then the second
question is what is around us like what
is around it there's two types of things
around us one is the static objects the
laying the curb the building the traffic
signs the the traffic lights and whatnot
and then there's another Road agents
that a movie
yes vehicles there's potentials there's
a cyclists and whatnot
right so so we're constantly keeping
track of all the objects or the
obstacles around us and then the third
question is then what will they do next
for all the movement moving ones well
this vehicle cut in in front of me we
have this vehicle TURN RIGHT will this
one have any interaction with our path
right so that this is related with
prediction and then the next one is
based on all this information we
collected what will I do next right this
essentially comes to the decision come
to the decision point say what should i
do should I break should I accelerate
should I turn then the final question is
that what what should I do to execute
right by using our hand or feet to
control the attending the steering
wheels or the brakes or other gas so
this related with the five fields
directly related with the five fields in
the autonomous driving which is
localization perception prediction
planning and then control
so essentially you can think that that's
basically by adding eyes brings hands
and feet to the vehicle then control it
then related to enable all this being
possible then we add simulation mapping
different sensor fusion and and all the
other related fields
so all this sounds simple but but in
reality what makes driving a lot harder
than the a lot of other AI systems is
2001 is the autonomous driving is
directly directly related with safety so
precision safety reliability are very
important 99.99% probably is definitely
not good enough it requires very high
precision and the second problem or
second challenge is just the open world
condition is just so unpredictable and
so complex complex it probably come more
complicated than most of the automated
system that human ever dealt with so to
illustrate that I'll just give you first
give you some small short videos some
snippets of the traffic scenarios that
we have encountered during our road
tests of course this is just a very
small snippets what we actually have
encountered are far more complicated so
this one is shows you a vehicle kotti
you can see we are following our enter
you a little bit this is how the sensors
tells us view this is the camera view
this is the light of you so so we are
actually behind that big vehicle let me
restart this so essentially we are we
are following that big vehicle and you
can notice there's a V code in the right
lane and then on the left lane there's a
vehicle first approaching but then this
vehicle decides to cut it in a very
short distance so essentially our
vehicle needs to detect this slowdown
and once that vehicle is changed laying
we have a safe distance between the US
and the front vehicle which we've sped
up and so this is the the whole
situation that we need to deal with and
then another
a scenario where it's in a foggy rainy
day we see a green light we're doing our
business coming in but then there's a
motorcycle that apparently went to a red
light and get in front of us so that
field of view that detection needs to be
happen fast enough in order to avoid
accidents then there could be people in
the in the reverse side of the traffic
right just just mind his own business
right in this case we actually slowed
down
we can't change lane because there's a
vehicle in the right-hand side so all we
can do is to knock over it
right so sort of nudging is important
there's another case where we are
following a big vehicle so that we think
it's just following it but out of
nowhere there's also a vehicle travel in
the reverse reverse side of the road and
in this case we cannot knock over it
because it's already in the link so we
have to stop and find another way out so
this is a night scenario we J walk
worker company because of the
construction we actually consider that
that pedestrian can be so so so
essentially we have to detect in time to
avoid the the accident in fact we see it
again we can see we actually detected
and and send us no signal slow down slow
down to the vehicle
anyhow just give you a glimpse of what
in reality what we need to deal with in
the open world
right I'm sure all of you have
encountered some near miss or even
encountered some accidents you can see
the driving situation on the open road
is just far more complicated than what's
in a controlled environment so I'll
spend another probably 15 minutes tell
you a bit about Pony AI what we have
done then then we are open for Q&A in
fact before I talk about the what we our
journey one of the most asked question
that we had is about why this name
people people is why nice name so so so
it's actually people to the time when we
started the company we wanted a name
that's meaningful memorable a name
that's cute or at least has some real
meaning associated with it right our
vision is to revolutionize the
transportation system so we wanted the
name that can capture the skill or the
meaning of what we wanted to do then we
think about the name right what what
what's the earliest form of
transportation is really the horse track
courage that's then it's we comes in the
internal combustion engine and then the
vehicle industry so I think the Pony is
actually directly associated with the
transportation with mobility of course
another hope secret hope we had was that
Pony is small is cute but then pony can
grow when pony can grow it's grow not
just not only just grow in size right
once we grow we have a horn out of us
that become a unicorn
with which 1/2 little nuns we already
become became a unicorn the this this
this summer but then later we grow we
have tenth horse then become a Decker
point that's just people go so that was
the secret hope so what do we do
essentially we are responsible for the
final product that's a safe and reliable
but look at the marketplace we choose to
focus on what we are good at which is
the AI technology which is the software
hardware integration so what we don't do
is we're not manufacturing vehicles
we're collaborating work with car oh
yeah mess with the Tier one suppliers
and then we are not sensor manufacturers
either so we work with lidar company
camera company in radar company so we
purchase most of the major hardware's
but then we do customize the computer
chips we do computer customization then
we we collect our own HD map then we do
all the AI algorithms to make the
autumns driving possible okay so what we
are now we actually this a good time we
we started exactly two years ago around
this time December 2nd so even a couple
more days it will be our two year
anniversary so we started in Fremont and
then we obtained the California open
world autumn's driving testing permit in
June last year and start testing in the
Bay Area then we opened a Beijing office
in March last year one of the milestones
that we achieved in Beijing is this year
in Beijing they start coming out with a
pump driving permit as well but that
permitting application process is far
more complicated of
more harder than what's in the
californian right in that testing
process the our fleet needs to test for
more than five thousand kilometres and
then we have to go through a stringent
testing require a testing phase it's
sort of like a how human can our driving
license you pass a different types of
tests and finally there will be a group
of experts that evaluate if the
technology is good enough so we we
obtain that the highest level of Tom's
driving the t3 so far and we remain to
be the owning startup that has obtained
that license then later this last year
we also open the Quantrill office in
fact this is the place where we have the
largest fleet and all the videos you
have seen so far is actually all in
control because that place has a
different weather condition has it's
also a newly built district of the
cities also it has a lot of interesting
scenarios that we can encounter so just
looking at this is why spreading this
for start-up but you might ask but
essentially they say startup needs to
focus needs to be concentrated but we do
see that driving itself is the global
phenomena and in Asia especially in
China the autumns driving tiffany's has
huge potential and even purely from
practical point of view it's very
beneficial it's almost like you are
learning driving and you are learning
driving in three different traffic
conditions simultaneously so we actually
maintain as I don't know if some of you
have a computer computer related
background essentially for us we shared
the same code base for all three
locations so it's so sort of three
places all learn how to drive on the
open road
and we can put our learning into the
same system so in that this is analogous
to how human learn in three different
environments simultaneously so that the
algorithm the technology itself can
evolve much faster on the funding from
we are backed by top investors our NGO
round was supported by Sequoia and ieg
our Iran was closed last year well end
of last year was Morningside large in
capital and the a platform was a clear
view and a rose a rose is a pure
subsidiary of fidelity and and some
other top investors such as DCM red
points Comcast ventures and and etc all
supported us in terms of product
development I think the speed and fast
iteration is the key because essentially
this is uncharted territory we don't
know what it's unlike all the other is
the established product there's still a
lot of unknowns that needs to be
explored so we think the key of the
speed of iteration is very important so
for us in the in the two years in
existence we actually has already
launched three versions of our product
the on the left hand side that was the
first version we launched in Fremont and
that's the one we used for the
California testing permeant then we
start our second generation in this
generation the noticeable difference
from that is the sensor fusion has come
into play right how do you understand
sensor fusion it's actually you can
think of lidar as I mentioned that
lighter use the laser to measure them to
accurately accurately measure the
distance but lighter has a drawback
lighter cannot detect color cannot
detect texture and also the resolution
is lower because
even even that big lighter is only 64
line so essentially it meets a 64 line
and just go through like this well as in
the traditional camera right and we know
the resolution is high it has color it
has texture and and all the good things
but it also has the drawback is that the
distance measurement is out of luck so
by combining this two it's more or less
like you have a 2d image but then in
most of the pixels or some of the pixels
there you have accurate distance
measurements so you can think of this
way or think about the other way is all
the lidar point cloud has color and the
has texture so by accurately combined
these two types of sensors you we
greatly increased the accuracy of
perception so in this version we start
using the sensor fusion so what were you
read about sensor fusion that's really
what it means but also there's a
challenge in sensor fusion different
types of sensors there are time
measurements needs to be exactly
accurate otherwise they're off so 214 so
we actually come up with own computer
chips to do the time synchronization
that and there of course other
challenging algorithms associated with
this and then just to month ago we
officially launched our third generation
which just by picture you can combine
it's it's you can see it's a lot more
production product ready right in terms
of not just the other looks but also the
comprehensive of the sensor suites that
we put in right besides the central Ida
we also put two small either in on the
side this is mostly because we start
going into residential area and in the
residential area there's there's a kids
and there's a pets that can be very
close by to the vehicle so that we need
to do the blind spot detection
give you another glimpse of for some of
the traffic with your wave right this is
a we see the bicyclist we try to not go
over but then there's a big vehicle
coming on the right-hand side and then
there's also pedestrian crossing road
and it's a rainy day so this is the
typical situation where again you can
see we have the not not over the
bicyclists the big vehicle on the right
hand side pedestrians crossing the road
so this is the daily situations that we
need to deal with so algorithms needs to
be robust enough to safely deal with all
these traffic situations what's going
forward I think the vehicles vehicle
itself needs to be smart needs to be
safe but to make this a successful
business there's a lot of other
components as needs to come in why is
the big infrastructure right we need to
do fleet management we need to do route
optimization there's a real-time
monitoring and everything else besides
that the vehicle needs to be a lot
production-ready and also a very
important factor into this is the UI is
the human machine interaction if you are
not driving the vehicle if the vehicle
doesn't give you a very intuitive
interface to tell you that actually I'm
safe right it's actually uses a I have
detected that bicyclist beside me don't
worry about it so essentially the we
need to come up with a very intuitive UI
to tell the passengers to actually give
the indication that it's safe right
we're constantly working on that to add
visual cues and also to add some sound
indicators so to save time I'll end my
talk with as I said we launched the
third version of our system we call
we branded as a pony alpha two year to
month ago at the Shanghai AI World
Conference the reason we debated there
was that I still remembered oh gosh no
it's about five years ago the first time
I was wrote in a autonomous driving
vehicle I think that all affect the
vehicle can actually drive by itself we
solve the driver so to me that consider
as a life-changing event so I wanted to
bring that event that experience to a
lot more other people and so happened to
be in the AI world conference there's a
big area that can be used to showcase
the Autons driving so we went there and
during that week there's more than a
thousand passengers rolling our vehicle
and experience that same effect as I did
before so end the talk with a video that
that we had in the AI conference
[Music]
[Applause]